you guys were trying to get pregnant for
a while and it wasn't easy right we
invited you to watch our yes I remember
that I remember that and and you had to
go to great lengths and get science
involved right which is quite common it
was really hard for Natasha she had to
you know take hormones and yet it's
really difficult the male part of the
IVF is like actually quite very fun you
know I mean at a certain point it wasn't
working and Natasha came to me and she
was like you know maybe you're the
problem which is how she put it she's
very supportive and and I was like sure
what do I sure maybe I am what I have to
do and she's like we have to go to this
clinic in Pasadena and you know you you
you you bust into a jar or not or not a
jar it's a it's a cup it's like a very
hipster place it's all mason jars you
know you go there and and they test it
out and I was like great you know I was
gonna I was gonna bust into something
that afternoon anyway why not
this is she's like I don't think you
actually understand how this works you
have to wait a full seven days you have
to like let him I'm sorry for the
gesture right she's like you have to
wait you have to have the sperm
concentrate yeah yeah I was trying to
censor myself and I'm glad some medical
terms
yeah sperm must concentrate yeah I'm
saying bust on anything that would be
very immature yeah so you have to like
last time you went seven days without an
orgasm you're probably seven years old I
see that memory yeah yeah yeah so I I do
it they just had one now
he loves comedy my god it's great TV so
I I did it you know Paris is about
sacrifice
I can wait seven days and I did I was i
day one I'm like okay I'm shadowboxing
day two I'm doing road work in the
street you know look and make this I can
make this day seven gets there I have
never been so excited to go to a medical
appointment in my life I bust down the
drawer
boom is the doctor in the house on the
bus a nut right now there's like real
families there's like real families in
the lobby dealing with real fertility
clinic issues like oh it's okay honey
adoptions always an option I'm like you
know what else is an option me jerk it
is thanks for censoring yourself but you
have to go into like you have to like go
into like a special room right oh yeah
and I'm what do they have there do to
help for your imagination I I'm so
excited and I'm so happy that you I'm so
thrilled that you asked Kohn and I cuz I
can't stop thinking about the porn
that's in there because I'm obsessed
with the idea that a doctor bought the
point there's a doc did the doctor but I
love that image of a doctor walking into
a porno shop with his nerdy little lab
coat like in my medical opinion I would
say the deep daggers 32 is the best
video so I'm so right off yeah
[Laughter]
doctors are Jewish I'm sure you
mentioning that I'm Jewish - you guys
got weird okay so I get into I'm so
excited to be there I get into the
little room and and I lets me in the
room I locked the door I let her out and
I lock the door and I turn on the TV to
see the porn and and I start flipping
through options and it is all gay porn
it is all gay porn and I'm like why is
the porn gay why like what happened I do
not anticipate this like did they why is
yeah did they look at my hair and outfit
and make a judgment call
yeah or are like all men secretly gay
and just waiting to get to a fertility
clinic and it's like it's pretty
specific it's yeah like meat and
potatoes like mainstream gay porn it's
all like I wouldn't know well just
imagine you know like a Nick Offerman
type walking through with an axe or
whatever yeah it's like you know all
like pushy gay roommate takes advantage
of his reluctant straight friend or
whatever like the only way it could have
been more specific to the situation at
hand if it was the video was like
middle-aged Pasadena dad has sex with
fertility clinic doctor today so anyway
I flip and I flip and I flip and I
finally did I did find one that was
boy-girl which is what I'm into and
I was about to press play and I thought
you know what no you gotta trust the
chef you know what I mean Rosie
you